un éxodo inédito en europa en décadas en
promedio unas 134.000 personas han huido
de ucrania cada 24 horas los países
fronterizos como rumanía y polonia son
los principales receptores de aquellos
que escapan del país bajo ataque según
el presidente polaco su país ha recibido
al menos un 60 por ciento de todos los
refugiados aseguro que proceden de más
de 170 países y que todos son
bienvenidos y recibirán el mismo nivel
de ayuda sin importar su procedencia por
supuesto el conflicto en ucrania es una
agresión rusa porque es la verdad somos
miembros de la otan y de la unión
europea y cooperamos con nuestros
aliados uno de los que salió fue uruguay
un estudiante sirio de 24 años que
residía en jarkko cuando rusia lanzó su
guerra contra ucrania esta es la tercera
vez que debe dejar sus planes y sus
sueños una situación que para él se
repite
cada vez que me acostumbro a un lugar
conozco más a mis amigos y luego lo dejo
todo y me voy es tan duro y
decepcionante para mí y lo odio pero qué
puedo hacer es la guerra donde quiera
que esté líbano tuvo una crisis
económica y también tuve que huir del
país así como ahora también de ucrania
me recuerda mucho a siria
como uruguay muchos en su vida llevan
tan solo lo que consideran necesario se
quedan sin comida y sin agua o deben
dormir en la calle episodios que
seguirán repitiéndose a causa de la
guerra esta semana la onu aseguró que el
conflicto bélico en ucrania puede
provocar que hasta 10 millones de
personas tengan que dejar sus hogares lo
que significaría que cerca del 25 por
ciento de la población ucraniana dejaría
el país